what did that make you feel when you
first saw Alpha zero play I was excited
I I didn't have any any sort of
existential thoughts I enjoyed watching
it completely destroy openings that
people thought were good
uh and it
it that experiment though has does have
some caveat in the sense that
I think Alpha zero was playing with a
full tank of servers and I think
stockfish wasn't which I think is what
one of the things people point out they
weren't playing since then they were
able to demonstrate much less yeah
uh but
also Alpha zero stopped developing
um they stopped developing it yes
which which sucks but again from their
perspective From deepmind's perspective
it's like all right well we took on this
really tricky game did something
honestly incredible they won
they won I mean well not just one I mean
they did it without any human
supervision so like uh without any
training on human expert games so only
through self-play which
I mean that's what learning is about
it's like it's what you think of as a
child a human child a toddler learning
from
you know somewhat nothing and becoming a
capable human that's that's what we
think of when we think about
intelligence so the fact that it's able
to play itself and become the best
player in the world at the game of Go
and all kinds of games it's just
incredible and obviously that inspired
the modern stockfish yeah now to do the
same all the same kind of self-play
methods